today's guest is a young man who is a
co-creator of the Dave Chappelle show
he has a Netflix special called three
Mike's and another half-hour special on
Netflix on comedians of the world he
also has a podcast called how Neil feels
and we're going to get into all of it
today he's a friend of mine from the
Comedy Store as well
give it up for the hilarious mr. Neal
Brennan
[Music]
as you come on stage
really yeah cuz why just put it in my
mouth people do get mad people I
remember when I first started podcast
and people would say him in and you your
breathing pattern I remember they wanted
a real specific way like now man this is
not gonna work for me you get a life
like this
yeah the iambic pentameter of breath is
really can you breathe it a little more
treble some guy wrote yeah this is not
gonna I've been listening to your
breathing and I'm and I refused I can't
I can't go on like this if you're gonna
breathe yeah people get real they just
need a three one more time like adding
cash yeah [ __ ] this guy [ __ ] change
the station but then I get worried that
some kid is getting abused or beat and
afterwards because of like sometimes I'm
you doing what some day I can't stay in
the breathing pattern it sends him into
a loop you know that's my fears go yeah
sure you don't do the headphones oh yeah
I do them sometimes and sometimes well I
mean you we don't have to I'm happy to
turn them on I don't know
okay was to feel this vibe with the
headphones and then see how you feel
with it off sometimes for me it's just
like a feeling kind of thing oh I like
it better cuz it's cool cuz mock you in
just sonically it's more pleasing and
like Sonic's it's just better like there
you are yeah I feel like I'm in a Tesla
little now yep yeah this that's where I
that's what I like you got the Tesla my
did I wanted to get the cheap one but
they didn't have any and I got the so I
at least the expensive one and what is
the price on that I've seen you in it
man you win and when you gotta show up
in the Tesla's at first I'm like ah [ __ ]
these guys are you know [ __ ] these
Jetsons you know right um but now I'm
starting I'm honestly starting to get a
little bit curious
I like gasoline I like the chance to
[ __ ] you think you have you been in
Joe's no dude they are so fast
it's it made me laugh out loud and I
don't care about speed I don't care
about I just do but I got in the car I
test drove it and I laughed out loud and
I was like all right
have to get this because I nothing makes
me laugh Wow yeah like I got it because
my but you if you if you ride in at once
you'll be like okay I'll go away and
what is it does it feel like does it
feel like I'm on a conveyor belt that's
what I imagined it would be like no it
just feels like you're in like FedEx or
something it's like you're being FedEx
somewhere I can't it's so fat you know
when you're like on a roller coaster and
it first starts yeah it's like that
whenever you want it to be okay so the
fun thing is if you cut people off but
you know just in traffic and not like
your intention but you just cut them off
and then you hit the gas it's like I'll
sorry I'm not gonna be a problem like
you thought you were mad and before they
even get mad you're gone that I love why
so people need to get mad now maybe you
don't even get people can't get mad
that's what's that's what's most
gratifying for me and in some rural
areas I bet you cut something off on a
test litters taking pictures like oh
yeah man they're just [ __ ] that yeah
hello police some I don't even know what
the [ __ ] it was but I'm reporting it you
guys should know about this thing I
think I undercover cop there's something
[ __ ] future man's here so now what
else is possible in there like do they
how accurate is the real you can drive
home without having to touch the skin
well okay on the freeway you can hit the
thing it will stay in the lane and it
will not it'll keep whatever number of
cars you tell behind like if it's stay
one cars distance that's what it'll get
to with whoever's in front of you or if
there's no one in front of you you set a
limit 85 now 70 cuz that's a great but
the problem is you can Reese you have to
like check in every 40 seconds okay you
have to like jiggle the steering wheel
every 40 seconds so what happens it
shuts down
yeah it'll beep and then it'll go you're
it what's funny as it kicks you off
autopilot like now you're you've lost
your privileges and what you just wake
up back at home
no then you have to dry.you for that
drive you can no longer do autopilot
like now you can't handle Wow
so your [ __ ] Kingdom what oh hell
yeah so and then so then you have to if
you want autopilot like it's happened to
me where I got kicked off autopilot yeah
so then I had to stop go to the store
and like start over and ask for it yeah
like baby I know how [ __ ] up but if
you could see to it to where I could do
the autopilot yeah Lou you have to start
baby yeah yeah yeah that's like it feels
like light skin are big yeah I think
about it cuz you in a regular car man
like I got a Jeep Grand Cherokee you can
just doze off for a second but you have
to wake back up yeah yeah this and they
won't kick you off you can repeatedly do
oh you can do that [ __ ] all the way to
San Diego bro if you're driving in the
middle of the night yeah bro I'll
[ __ ] take about 20 seconds I'll set
my timer on my phone for about 20
seconds and totally shut down yeah sure
of course and it's totally safe yeah I
mean it's you have to get up about that
you can't hit snooze a Hugh hit [ __ ]
snooze twice you know yeah you're gonna
wake up in a 7-eleven let's check it's
real risky out there wow so you're in
now did you does it make you feel less
like a man like less manly to not have
gas yeah no because if you if you hit
the gas once yeah if you hit the
acceleration once you've never felt like
more of a man in your life no way I'm
Joe Rogan has won the I know and at
first we biggest man any of us have ever
met he's the greatest man top to bottom
values wise physicality ideology [ __ ]
this guy does UFC he [ __ ] with alien
DMT all the acronyms H he does all the
acronyms and he does it all yay
yo yeah okay [ __ ] he does him also so
uh
so he does all of it so he and he's got
one so it's good enough for Joe I don't
see but when you go back in a regular
card as if you're going back in the past
it feels like a failure
it really feels like you failed like man
this is [ __ ] [ __ ]
and honestly I can't I mean backing up
doesn't feel right just none of it works
once you've once you've gone to a Tesla
it's like going to a flip phone dude it
reminds me that's what I'm saying Ramon
g34 I was like a probably about a
three-year hold out on a cell phone I
was like God is [ __ ] ain't a really yeah
you didn't you dude was like this is not
gonna happen I think this is insane yeah
why you didn't like that you were always
available I think I'm a traditionalist
you're an analog guy yeah I am
I get it my brain runs a little bit more
analog and I'm just a little bit more I
need that I just yeah just wasn't ready
for it I said man this [ __ ] is insane
you know nobody's gonna believe it's a
if you tell somebody something into a
phone and they hear it but is it as true
as if you tell somebody something in
person yeah I had thoughts like that
like is there the same value on the on
the whatever The Voice or whatever like
does it mean anything I think you're
kidding a little bit and I also think
you're not kidding at all yeah like I
think there's you know there's a thing
called epigenetics which is a parent's
DNA isn't you like that like it's
basically like your parents can
experience something and then you have
the react the trauma right but 1800 [ __ ]
in you yeah I believe when was your
father born no in 1910 goddamn that's
insane so yeah I think my grandfather
was born in 1880 so I believe I do have
some of that yeah I'll probably have
some [ __ ] yeah I mean my dad had a
[ __ ] his boy you know his neighbor had
a horse I remember and they had a horse
for a little while that they let him
watch it yeah but yeah I thought the Val
you know I remember thinking the value
of communication is gonna really it does
it just degrade yeah it degraded and you
I mean you were right
you're right it's too much yeah it's
like much but when I got one
I remember thinking holy [ __ ] dude
there's nothing I can't do yeah yeah
I'll write your own ticket man yeah
[ __ ] world's yours yeah your and your
also that's also true yeah like it's
[ __ ] it's a big deal its first cell
phones a big deal they just re-released
the razor phone yeah saw that and it was
like I thought about that time and 99
1998-99 having a cell phone it was a
thing was yours a razor would you have I
think I had a razor at one point I the
black razor do you give that t-mobile
sidekick ever oh yeah oh yeah absolutely
not long though cuz they didn't really
they came and then they would then they
went away yeah but yeah it was a bit
yeah getting emails on a phone was crate
that was a sidekick who's the first one
sidekick you flip up crap and it made
you seem cozy people heard that noise
yeah what is it I got the [ __ ] people
dropping drinks and [ __ ] as you sow so
yeah it was a big deal but you are an
analog guy yeah do you feel like that is
your problem I know that's like a big
but you feel like you're you are
uncomfortable in a lot it's like you
seem at ìlet you seem at ease and then
at the same time you feel like you don't
understand what's going on some I just
saw this recently man I sometimes I have
a I'm upset that time moves so fast it's
like I just I just feel like I can't
ever win I just can't ever really get a
grasp of what's going on and it keeps
happening you know and it really does I
think sometimes frustrate me a little
bit what is the what what do you want to
get a grasp on I think just to feel like
I'm kind of inking that everything that
I'm gonna be able to control like I
guess that I'm in control you know that
I'm okay you know okay I got the hang of
what's going on now yeah without things
neat changing so much and is that within
relationships or that's within
everything
I think that's is within existence
really yeah so I think yeah I just just
thinking about that the other day I just
sometimes feel you know not like it's a
bad thing but like I just realized oh
wow I have this this irrational idea
that like almost a resentment against
time because I can't get a Kentucky it
won't let me grasp everything at once
you know it won't let me
you can't organize everything is well as
you need to because it just keeps
happening it keeps going and and also
then I think because I'm probably lazy
sometimes and so it's like damn give me
a chance
broke your lazy time I don't I don't
know your schedule but you seem pretty
active yeah am I wrong
uh I think I I think I procrastinate I
think sometimes you know what I thought
the other day man I put I set this weird
bar in my mind that everything needs to
be perfect or like everything needs to
be perfect but then I also know this
thing about myself then I procrastinate
sometimes and so I will set both it's
like I will set the bar high oh yeah you
know that's one of the reasons people
procrastinate is fear of perfection mmm
or not fear of perfection they're
perfectionists so you're like well I
can't start now because I'll get to it's
not right yet like I don't have it set
up you're gonna fail you're gonna fail a
lot of procrastination is just fear of
failure yeah this is feeling like you
can't and then you'll start when you go
well if I don't I'm [ __ ] if I don't
start now so that's the only like the
fear of being [ __ ] is greater than the
fear of being imperfect mm-hmm and then
if once you get to that point you go
okay they'll start or like you have to
start yeah I'm that last-minute starter
a lot of jobs but things are working out
for you man yeah things are going okay
man it's crazy this year I got in so
much fear man I just got you know it's
just and I'm not trying to sound like
ungrateful or just yet this year was
just [ __ ] crazy but I was crazed just
a crazy year it was busy and it was hard
and it was what did you find hard about
it because I think people from the
outside in people would assume it was
it's been great for you it's if people
would think it's probably the best year
your life right
yeah and I think I just couldn't feel
that I just couldn't I just think just
got real scared man I got real scared
but what what up just like of that
things we're gonna I think for one of
not maybe knowing who I was as things
got more successful you know like I'd
always been this like I'd always felt
like I didn't have a chance a little bit
mhm and I'd always really liked that had
always been something that I really like
carried me oh yeah you were like an
underdog yeah like an underdog like the
underdog who wouldn't get you were
getting [ __ ] and you were they are not
helping me and yeah [ __ ] and
yeah and then you and you're like oh
wait they you're not I mean you are
still but that's part of your appeal
yeah and I just didn't yeah yeah I just
but then I felt like I didn't know how
to be I don't know I felt like I didn't
know how to be successful and then I got
scared I started to get real scared and
I got real like controlling even this
year like everything just I wanted
everything to be I needed help and I was
afraid to ask for help and so then
everything would felt like it was on me
what did you need help with just with
just with like touring and doing that
kind of stuff and being willing to like
just trust that other people know what's
good and I don't know I think I just had
like a lot of dislike I mean for me a
lot of it goes back to like my
alcoholism stuff it's just a lot of that
stuff just flared up like just fear just
came up everywhere yeah it just came up
everywhere man I was just I don't know
man I just got kind of scared and it's
not like a self-pity thing I'm not
feeling sorry for myself like and I also
I couldn't feel gratitude I really
needed to feel grateful when I was and I
felt so grateful for for the past couple
years man and then I just I just had a
tough time man and I just got real
scared honestly bro I got real what were
using what were you you were afraid that
it was all gonna go away yeah I was
afraid that I was just gonna mess it up
yeah you know I was afraid that you know
that I was a phony I was afraid that I
was like a liar just I was afraid that I
was no good just a lot of just
self-worth just didn't it just was hard
you know not in a bad way I think the
only thing that you would [ __ ] up is if
you weren't yourself yeah I think that's
the only
that's the own people like you because
you are your unique like just watching
them known you probably eight years or
somebody's watching you
it's been cool watching you go from I
gotta say your hair cut from the outside
in was a turning point seemingly yeah
cuz you you were just like trying to be
kind of like la you're appealing or
something or something I don't know what
you were trying to be just like a like
just more like everybody else yeah and
then you got then you started doing this
with your hair and it felt like
everything fell into place
yeah like oh like myself yeah like if
you felt like more like yourself and you
you like you started being more yourself
on stage yeah and being weirder on stage
and being more regional or southern than
you'd been before yeah and and and then
and then you start a podcast it just
felt like all these things started
happening in sequence and from the
outside in and just a guy who sees you
at night it seemed like once you had
that hair it was like he's empowering
am I wrong no it felt a very empowering
man I think all my life to I've had a
big nose I've always been scared to have
like like real short hair cuz there's
less things to hide behind you know
you're here's the thing about you that
I've always said about you that you
you're good looking and you don't think
you are yeah
you are good looking like I bet if you
they asked most 5s most women would say
you're like an eight yeah I say yeah I
thought brush my teeth I am an eight but
I believe everybody's an eight if they
take care if they clean up and they take
care of themselves I believe that okay I
don't agree okay I respectfully disagree
with that but you're and you're
definitely an eight because you're like
kind of Tang and olive skin you got
night you know like your was symmetrical
the big nose thing I don't think it's
true I mean it's fine and I have a big
nose but like it mine's bigger than
yours mom I'd love that lean yeah I got
that mind
I got the open nose maybe I love that
[ __ ] Li yeah you had that tear that
scar you got like meat
so yeah thing is [ __ ] like a thought
bro I feel like it should be in a thong
sometimes you got that donk on your face
man yeah so anyway growing my hair
longer once I was like yeah and I think
four years I'd try to audition in
Hollywood and been like I just I hated
it I [ __ ] hated going auditions yeah
absolutely hated it I felt uncomfortable
I just was scared yeah I just didn't
know I didn't like it and I didn't want
to admit that I didn't like it I was
afraid to say you know what I don't like
this I felt like I had to do it and then
yeah once I was just kind of like oh
I've never I saw some pictures myself I
said I'm never gonna have real long hair
you know I had it when I was really
young right but I'm never gonna have it
again unless I grow it now and then once
I grew my hair out man I started to feel
like a [ __ ] you know like just like a
king bruh just like somebody who had a
[ __ ] it's like I'm gonna dick on the
back of your head bro yeah it feels
empowering dude it's what it looks like
that cuz it's like hey you know what I'm
gonna look how I look it then you I deal
with it this looks the way you probably
fit looks like your character yeah it
looks like what I would assume your
character and it also looks like your it
looks like your character like your your
values and all that [ __ ] but it also
looks like the not like theof on skater
but like the thing that's funny about
you is also that yeah it's the guy that
wants to an adult that wants his hair
like this in 2019 it's beautiful yeah is
who you are and that's like it [ __ ]
yeah I don't I'm glad that I was right
about because it was like it seems like
once he grew his hair like this
everything J yeah yeah I guess I got
scared to like say that I wasn't feel it
was hard for me to tell how I was
feeling and and then I I was like nobody
wants to hear somebody who's doing well
complain nobody wants to hear him
complain yeah
and so that kind of got tough for me too
like even on just the regular episodes
of this podcast
just by myself to talk about things
because I just felt like man I just I
don't want to be I don't want to have
self-pity but I don't know what's going
on right now I'm just you know I'm just
I was just I was just scared
you know just scared really when I think
about it and how does it resolve or did
it it's just kind of resolving I'm just
like trying to get more like in a
12-step right now and just really
focusing on that and like were you not
doing that I was but it might hit my
that my program had gotten real small
whenever I was just working all the time
yeah you know my life got big in my
program got small yeah and I think I was
angry of being at some success because I
thought I would feel better yeah yeah
that's the other thing when I do you
think like well that if putting
conditions on your happiness yeah going
well I'm not happy now I'm not even
gonna allow myself to be happy now
because I don't deserve it
yeah and then you good [ __ ] happens and
and you're like this didn't work either
but yeah what's gonna work the [ __ ] is
gonna work and what I I will say that it
is gratifying to be the times I've had
like you know weeks or months of like
attention is gratifying it feels good
yeah I mean it feels gratifying to it
feels shallow to admit it but it feels
good when people yeah that feels good
our ego feels good we know good yeah
nice whenever people acknowledge you yes
and but at the same time it it shitty
that you that you that we lit I feel
like it's partially like American to
only be happy if you accomplish X yeah
and and I've been trying to do a thing
and it's very degree success but where
I'm like no just give yourself that
esteem for not for not for nothing just
for Y put it on some why leave it up to
a situation or the way to make you feel
good about you to make you feel good
it's like I can just feel good because
life is short
and and like I you know it's like I used
to beat myself up for not being as funny
as Blanc and it's like all right maybe
I'm never gonna be as funny as [ __ ]
bill burr or or did Chris or Dave or
when it's like what so I'm supposed to
[ __ ] sulk my whole life well yeah I
wanna [ __ ] have a fun time with my
skill level and you're funny is totally
different to of course yeah of course
we're like I have different talents
right we don't recognize those things we
just yeah we set these things and it's
like yeah and it's yeah we just set
these comparisons and it's good for
business it is good for American
business when everyone feels insecure
that everybody feels like they got to
work harder and rise & grind and all
that right definitely but if you just
get to the point of like no I I'm I want
to have a fund I want to feel good yeah
like I meditate and then in the last two
minutes I just go like just feel good in
your body for no reason yeah just just
feel good your job on in on earth is to
feel good that's my job to make myself
to have as much serotonin flowing
through my body as I posit own and
jockiboi don't ya like and and without
without drugs or drink whatever just
getting things going feeling that is
they that to me is the mark of a life
well-lived
yeah how good did I feel
minute-to-minute a membra honestly no I
feel you 100% like yeah like I and
without drinking or drugs or would have
but like how did I [ __ ] have fun did
I have fun that's all I think about now
when people die did he have fun did she
have a good time not did was she
upstanding and did he enjoy himself did
he wear the mink ever yeah exactly like
d1 twice yes was he and member was he a
respected member of society no [ __ ] it
did you enjoy did you like it that's the
thing is when that haircut is you or
[ __ ] liking it yeah that's it
you [ __ ] my values my my barometer is
I don't care about anybody else's mine
what do it you know what I also been
doing closing my ears like literally
like weird like a little kid where you
like close your ears and it's like
acoustic thing and it's going what do I
like yes what do I like and then you go
I like ice cream or it'll the most basic
[ __ ] comes up I like ice cream
I like jerking off I like whatever you
like you come up and just know that yeah
just do that that's that's what we'll
just do that as much as you can without
[ __ ] up your life yeah and that's the
hard it's the hardest thing to remember
the hardest thing to remember like [ __ ]
everyone else's values what do you like
and if it's like if you're if you're
victimizing people you're doing it wrong
right right
like not without you know without being
abusing yourself or abused and you know
relationships or whatever but just what
do you like that's the lowest that's
just between you and you yeah do that as
much as you can yeah yeah yeah yeah
having that personal relationship with
yourself and just yeah that's huge it's
yeah we lose it yes some of that's
gotten lost I think and he's definitely
an American thing like it's it's such a
blessing to be able to live here and
stuff but at the same time that we start
to see like the D value the D values
ization I think of being a human once
you like at a certain level of like
comfort and stuff you really fall out of
like whatever tribal or whatever like
yeah pink shoe whatever confidence stuff
is inside of you you that's the nice
thing about 12-step programs yeah is
you're gonna try your that's probably
what you like about it oh yeah man I
just saw a guy at a gym this morning
last night I'm somewhere and I see yeah
I went to a meeting last night now and
it is man it's one of the things that I
didn't have here in LA yeah it's like
sitting just sitting across from
somebody and talking about we could talk
about how we feel like we can have
conversations like this a lot of times
where it's a little bit more like you
know cuz yeah just like about what soil
or emotion I need
like hey I need help I talk I have to
call someone today and tell them not
good news and that kind of heard
something I have to make a call and that
stuff always scares me so it's like now
I can ask somebody who's done it before
or he's older than me who has a business
or something how do I do this you know
and they'll tell me they're like it's
gonna be okay
you know don't let it spin in your head
where you're up yeah after the night
you've had nine conversations with the
guy yeah now I don't have to do that
that [ __ ] doesn't have to happen I can
say okay you know I'm powerless over the
situation with somebody else I know can
help me yeah and it can be a friend it
just yeah it creates a Brotherhood you
know yeah I've never gone to 12-step
programs have been like [ __ ] I shouldn't
of coming yeah [ __ ] waste in my cup
it's always like at least nice yeah it's
at best incredibly helpful and at least
like oh this is cool
yeah yeah I got in this year my program
got real small so I didn't have any of
the tools I was needing like I had no
tools I was just like holding on in our
podcast you it was just more about like
helping people and being involved in
people's lives and I just felt like
disconnected at some points and yeah and
I should have just talked about that
like why I feel disconnected well I've
watched your thing about the you know
why you got sober thing yeah and that's
like one of your a very popular clip of
yours right yeah yeah and that's what
that's what people like about you man
yes that you don't understand
you if you were like a logo you'd be
like a guy just carrying a bunch of [ __ ]
around they don't like that guy right
there yeah you like you're like I don't
know what but it's like feelings it's
just like emotional [ __ ] and discomfort
and like you're walking around like I
don't know what to do peach cobbler it
has one of them down matches [ __ ]
fireworks like a bunch of clothes it's
like wet clothes like the dryer broke
and you got [ __ ] and you're looking
for like a place to settle
down you're just carrying a bunch of
[ __ ] around looking for a place to set
it and figure and that's your appeal
yeah that's like so and people and
watching you struggle is the emotion is
like the fun of it that's the like not
the fun of it but it's it's fun to watch
a guy who doesn't think he knows what
he's doing but you do know what you like
you if you talk it out you'll be okay
yeah I just quit talking it out man
yes didn't have a place to talk it out
and then everything not everything
everything's good everything's okay but
my head started to swirl that everything
was you know just a lot of negative
things came in and and so then I just
wasn't I was living my dream and not
even enjoying uh Tennessee not enjoying
it but I felt like I was just it was a I
was just scared I don't know I just felt
[ __ ] scared and it was a huge just a
lot just a lot of changes like well
that's the other thing people don't
realize about fame or success or some it
is isolating and it's a little scary cuz
you're like [ __ ] it's like having a
superpower samuri like [ __ ] like people
know me not just did [ __ ] it's just
different and it's less human it's less
human yeah it's less of a human it's
less of a normal human experience like
even Fame a thousand years ago was like
every one of the Treadwell everyone on
the tribe knew everybody anyway but I
you got a little more respect you felt
like I'm the shaman and people think I'm
cool yeah a rock thrower yeah yeah I
throw I'm the [ __ ] road charter rocks
yeah the guy that [ __ ] and it's a one
guy and night by the fire yeah just huge
[ __ ] like big ass yeah I gotta sleep
yeah I gotta rest
yep so it is so when you get in these
situations where and then we also think
like famous people are kind of full of
[ __ ]
so or they're phony or they're like
putting it on so it just it's it it's a
lot of weird it's just a lot of weird
dynamics yeah which is why I it eats
everybody up oh you see it yeah
I see it in a lot of these AAA rooms and
stuff like that you see a lot of people
and and that gets scary - it's like well
what do what what type of popularity do
you want how much do you want what is um
it's just yeah it's just so all of that
just a lot of that coming into my head
and just trying to figure it out and not
having a lot of not going to a lot of
meetings and having like a look and
trust in those things it's a different
it's a different kind of discomfort like
it's like a new discomfort it's a new
it's a new way that you don't understand
the world
yeah like well I didn't understand the
world before and I've kind of figured it
out or I got out you escaped into this
other like well now I'm popular and
famous and successful and then you're in
that you're like uh [ __ ] this is its own
[ __ ] ball it's its own rules and
dynamics and [ __ ] yeah I just wanted to
feel like myself and I just couldn't you
know and so now I'm working more towards
uh it's not even working more I'm just
trying to just let go with stuff and you
know kind of trust a higher power and
and just get him back into my program
more yeah and it makes me feel more
dialed in and makes me feel like I want
to help other people and and I hadn't
had that feeling for like about six
months and it's tough when that was like
the feeling that I loved the most was
acting like oh there's other people that
struggle and it's one thing I love about
you Neil is that you always like are
good at talking about um like and it's
not like self-pity [ __ ] it's just like
this is what's kind of going on in my
head yeah and how it's relating to the
world around me well that's the thing
that like and you love that kind of
stuff I love cuz I don't have any shame
about it I don't have any because I
started going with like a therapist when
I was like 23 yeah so it's been I just
stopped
you're like the Larry Fitzgerald of
thing yeah man I got dreads and [ __ ] and
we have to make herbal references you're
the blackest guy we've had except me he
actually was like Neil man can you go
over and [ __ ] but he said bless bless
vo so you know he's black
so uh yeah that you don't I started
going and I just stopped when I came to
that conclusion of the I had a therapist
that was forcing me into relationships
like not not for it but I went to
therapy because I'd be in romantic
relationships and be like I don't really
like it that much
yeah I'm like you know I can do it I can
like robot my way into like be
compassionate be that it is like be like
the stuff women want you to be yeah
and I can do in some and I just was
alone and all that yeah all of it man
and you know consider emotionally like
intuitive oh yeah what's going on yeah
like listening and yeah yeah and and I
didn't love it right and and she was
like I you know so I would just force my
way I tried to force myself to feel more
comfortable in relationships I wasn't
really supposed to be in I wasn't in
love with the people but I didn't know
that mmm and finally like a year ago I
was like hey what if my role on earth is
not to be a husband or a boyfriend what
if that and she was like well I just
think he'd be happier and I was like but
I don't know if I will be right and I
want to feel okay right instead of
always having this fight yeah like even
the idea of like I'm looking for someone
to complete me right no I'm completely
complete I'm not an [ __ ] for saying
that I don't want to feel like well I'm
looking out the window like is she here
ya know maybe someone is for me and I'll
meet her and it'll be great you don't
want to hear goo goo dolls and have hope
you know yeah yeah like everything's
come I thought even I don't have a hope
it's just right not hope but not not
this constant a little bit of fresh it
like yeah like sure yes it's a pressure
and I feel like women feel it too and
won't admit to it imagine how much they
feel it if you yeah yeah like that they
need to be a certain kind of way to get
a guy to like it all those in Condon and
it's like it's
my version of cutting my hair like that
where I just was like I don't want to
feel like I'm I'm just a boyfriend I'm
an unsuccessful boyfriend yeah I'm I'm a
failed husband somehow even though I'm
not like and that's been a huge one from
Wow like and to I stopped going to there
because I was going to therapy for that
to feel like well I'll just be a better
person all than all and it's like now
dude it's about the relationship with
yourself and accepting that you're fine
yeah fine yeah yeah good whatever you
are as long as you don't drink or do
drugs you're great
yeah and even if you do you're great
yeah like you'd prefer not to but if I
get lifelong whatever yeah but if you're
so I don't have any shame about emotions
or I just find it interesting I find it
as interesting is as basketball or you
know a man like this right people like
oh I'd love to see that game too oh
here's the emotionally unavailable
people playing the depressed people
oh [ __ ] you my always why don't they
have a family few with stereotypes the
[ __ ] good yeah that's really funny
okay so I love that I love that cuz
there's these weird normal energies and
things that it's like oh yeah my if a
girls don't like me or if they're not
throwing themselves at me or if Earth if
I don't have a girl for something that
I'm not okay yeah that you're not it's a
cultural value thing but but okay I'll
agree to that for sure there's a lot of
pressure from coral-like but also
there's something probably inside most
of us and it would make sense that it's
not in everyone just like some people
are good at something and some people
have or not but that do you feel like at
some point it's almost like a selfish
thing like okay I'm going to like be
able to look at it like that too like am
I just I'm not opposed to it that's the
thing is I'm not opposed to it I I just
don't want to feel
I think a lot of people are in
relationships that they I mean
statistically look at marriages those
are the people that were sure they found
the right person
yeah and that's half of those don't work
yeah we say it like on Big Brother when
they go in that secret room and tell how
they really feel always said that right
for every wedding you I mean that's what
I was saying I did a joke there night
that weddings are basically like jury
duty for everyone but you don't get to
say like you like my I got a feeling I'm
not gonna say anything
the I don't I I just think most people
are in the wrong relationships and
because they were like well it becomes
this musical chairs thing well like
especially for women because they have a
biological clock and they want to
reproduce and they're like [ __ ] close
enough
imagine that imagine putting like a dam
I mean every woman's vagina is basically
like who's that man with Danny Glover
you know I'm talking about Mel Gibson
yeah but in that movie with a hot hot
quiz pop pop quiz pop quiz hot shot yeah
it's a lethal weapon yeah yeah they have
a certain amount of time for the bomb
good yeah imagine having that in your
[ __ ] body all the time and by the
other thing about the vagina is like we
didn't have a baby this month I hope you
like blood [ __ ] yeah and then three
days of blood Oh like it's like the
Bible Eve [ __ ] it yes every [ __ ]
month like dude give it a [ __ ] rest
with the blood because I didn't sergeant
make a baby yeah it's a big deal it's
like a Stephen King novel it really is
like what again with the blood so yes
like Jesus cry get it you want to have a
baby stop bleeding on me um pop pop quiz
hotshot is actually from speed I don't
know if you're oh my god Danny Glover
with Dennis Hopper yeah I am in a race
with with Mel Gibson with Mel Gibson um
what do you think about that Nick about
what about what Neil said about the
relationship thing I'm wondering like
how you ended up dealing with it and
like finding you seem like maybe you
just hide it well
but you seem like you found some
contentment or I did find it in that
realization Wow
and like I did that three Mike showed
the next show was about that the next
show was about I'm I'm good I'm all
right yes despite all the ways that
you're telling me I'm not alright I
swear to you I'm alright
iris I swear I [ __ ] swear I'm alright
see I respect that I believe you because
I know that you look like I've seen over
the years how we you know we talked
about especially a lot of relationship
stuff and about that I know you've gone
through the proper channels I mean if
there's anything oh you're you're a
thinker and an analyzer mhm you know
yeah so I could see yeah I just think
that do you ever feel that pressure Nick
like there's this invisible pressure in
the world that a hundred percent I mean
that rising grind line you had earlier
like it's just I mean I listen to Jaco
too much so I'm like if I'm not getting
up at 4:30
what like yeah that's art we are just
you like it do you like it
that's the only thing it's like do you
even like when people are I was saying
to somebody they got mad at me but I was
like having a good disposition is
basically a six-figure job unbeli it's a
six-figure salary your if you're happy
naturally you're you're doing better
than almost everybody yeah
and that's the thing that people never
talk about it's like disposition is the
number one commodity it's the time it's
the most valuable thing in the world
yeah yeah I talked to my sister on the
phone man she's the happiest girl I know
and they live right by the interstate
like illegally close to the interstate
like I'm sure yes someone who has
anything to do is owning road yeah like
like you'll see a children's ball from
their yard balanced across six lanes
yeah so it's a really alarm homework
flow yeah totally and I'll call her on
FaceTime and she's sitting over there
you know she's got her two kids and
they're beautiful and they're smart and
um and the dog ate the baby or somebody
you know things are going on it's
alright oh definitely yeah but then you
know Theo we're not gonna we're just
enjoying ourselves they're having a
blast
having a [ __ ] blast and I'm envious
every time I talk to them in yeah of the
[ __ ]
just like the ham like man yeah like
that and that's like literally you
cannot buy that right you cannot it
doesn't matter how many pot how many
download in order to change your
disposition is so [ __ ] hard and the
only thing that does it is 12-step
programs yeah I always say the only time
I see people change are when they almost
die or they go to 12-step program that's
the only way in as an adult that I've
ever seen people change yeah
like [ __ ] I almost died and now I
understand life in a different way or I
go to 12-step programs and every single
day I have to like re-calibrate myself
yeah to this to a way better value
system yes than the one that we're all
soaking in yeah that were rising and
grinding and [ __ ] like no legs yeah
like [ __ ] Pro to [ __ ] games can't
stop walls not and is there some way to
get a triplets and you're like yeah like
stop for a second just stop lady
yeah I can't stop that will you gotta
stop yes so so I so that's the thing
with the relationship thing is like
feeling like it's okay it's okay to feel
the way you feel yeah quit making that
yeah quit letting everyone make us feel
like just good we don't we don't have
somebody it doesn't mean you're nobody
else is sitting in the world thinking
you're a failure because you don't have
somebody you you're still your person
you're still and you can be a happy
person yeah don't let that be that
element I also have a [ __ ] fun time
we never sell time yeah have your it's
like I was I wrote in my notes thing
like I want to meet someone who's having
a funny conversation with themselves mmm
like that's what I'm would say people go
what kind of person you want just are
you [ __ ] having a funny do you
when you walk around do you think funny
[ __ ] or think interesting [ __ ] like
that's the kind of person I'd like to
meet instead of like a square
yeah or like one of us that's having
this conversation but not really this is
good Commerce no this is a good cover
but I may be somebody that's living like
yeah like always yeah like in
interesting whatever like whatever
people call this a deep conversation
it's it's it's all conversation should
be around this deep
yes far as I'm concerned yeah I get
bored otherwise or just I've already had
it at me in times well everything else
is just trivia everything else is like
so wha
would you would you eat yeah yeah
everybody wants to know everybody a what
you come on man yeah somebody says what
y'all have come you got to do better
good it is so nice though and I'm
walking around in my head is having a
fun time yeah that's the [ __ ] singing
yeah here in association thinking about
something make it a black eye like a big
black eye yeah I'm black eye at the gym
you don't even know why it's funny but
he liked it you like you liked it he
liked it maybe he knows you maybe he
doesn't maybe I just felt yeah yeah
you're walking off you're like I didn't
do slavery I'm good yeah I'm straight
yeah it's regular white people thought I
had a black homeless guy one time say
what's up white boy it's [ __ ] great
and I knew he meant it I knew what he
meant and I and he knew who I was in
that moment so yeah
silver bells Don tonton silver bells oh
what's that up there on the ridge is
that Santa nope
that's a wallet the ridge wallet helps
you carry what you need every day if you
need something man you can have it with
you sometimes you're at home you're like
man which had money
wish I'd have credit card wish I had a
little picture of my little lady you
know a little two by three or whatever
those little wallet size well now you
can ridge streamlines how you carry cash
and cards in that flagship Ridge hitter
right here and also in their new
commuter backpack they want to make the
most out of what you're bring
with you so don't bring like a you know
don't bring a big knapsack or don't
bring a donkey with a bunch of water on
his side's and also did you know that
half the donkey population might be gone
in a few years because they are being
used now for Chinese medicine dude I
don't want that donkey in me the ridge
is so confident that you don't even have
to be that's how good it is it's super
durable heard that and that's you can
get it now and you can get a discount
10% off go to Ridge comm slash Theo and
use code Theo for 10% off and just go to
Ridge comm you know if you go to Ridge
comm you can get it and you go to Ridge
comm slash Theo and use code Theo for
10% off enjoy that front pocket carry
well I'll be honest with you I'm going
this afternoon you get my butt waxed and
also to I'll probably shave this evening
what I'm talking about is taking hair
off of my body and it's um there's
something very unique about taking hair
off your body you feel like a chef you
know you feel like somebody that's gonna
cook up something maybe you you might
cook up a cornrow or something if you
put enough hair in a pot and know how to
use the utensils but what I'm talking to
you about is manscaped it's number one
in men's below the belt grooming so
often we think of cutting everything up
above and doing nice shapes on our chest
for the football season but now it's
time to really take care of that junk
area you know everybody wants to have
that nice looking Weiner and have that
really that you know that Corvette of
[ __ ] but you have to take care of the
hair manscaped is changing the grooming
game their perfect package 2.0 that
perfect package you'll find the electric
trimmer called that lawn mower you know
what I'm saying this thing ain't
gas-powered I don't put gas near my
crotch
it has waterproof skin safe technology
and it'll protect you from nicking your
sack you can create less mess by
trimming in the shower sexy boy
get 20% off and free shipping with the
code Theo th EO at manscaped comm they
got that perfect package 2.0 includes
that chafing anti chafing boxer-briefs
as well come with a pair of man panties
for you and also they do an anti chafing
ball deodorant 20% off and free shipping
with the code Theo at manscaped dot-com
I've been taking care of my crotch now
it's your turn you tried you tried some
unique therapies well you tried we'll do
that and we'll talk about Shanghai kid
yeah oh you tried some unique therapies
um and um and I wanted to clear out that
yes depression depression what do you
got that electromagnetic one yeah so I
tried I when I started going to therapy
in 20 when I was 23 they put me on
Zoloft because they knew how great was
it in the beginning amazing well I can
drink nine gin and tonics they did not
get thrown I liked it I liked it for
like a decade though oh I was good I
didn't it wasn't a drinking thing for me
I just liked I liked it oh yeah I loved
it Brock you get up early I felt would
you would you last longer when you had
sex
oh I wasn't odd last longer when I
jerked off for sure sure alright same
thing
definitely way definitely dude yeah
because you were always looking a last
longer
yeah yeah right yeah you wanted to save
at a certain point is like for I'm the
one who's I'm gonna have the orgasm what
have we making it last for it ah it's
like my what's that and Greek guys
pushing the ball up the hill this is not
yeah like yeah why am i yeah where
you're looking for just the right thing
to say like what just finish did I could
press my butt against the corner of the
counter right when I do is that true
yeah I believe that because you couldn't
MIT I was a young bro when I was young
yeah great yeah and you just got I don't
know so when people judge other people
for what they're into it's like I used
to press your butthole against the
counter against ya know Liam so it was
linoleum - of course
was the oh so so I so I did that for a
while and it worked and then it just
stopped working but like after a decade
so then I started doing other [ __ ] and
none of them worked other pills no but
okay so zoloft neat right other pills
and none of them work yeah so then I
just I think I went on reddit and and
typed in like alternative depression
sleeping in the water yeah next thing
you know so they know they had there was
a thing called TMS which was a
transcranial magnetic stimulation right
that's the way the thing I like people
make fun of reddit but it's the only
place by the way right it's the reason
podcasts work yes that it's unorganized
organization it's like it's off the grid
but on the grid it's like an alternative
way to do [ __ ]
so it's this it's what podcast is to
radio reddit is to the internet or
society and transcranial magnetic
stimulation so it's basically like a
tapping thing it's a it feels like
tapping but it's a magnet it's an MRI
beam stimulating a party brain that's
known to cause depression did that for
its forty five half hour sessions
natively right over like a month and a
half
obviously like four days a week did that
four years ago and it worked great
then well it worked great I stopped
taking Zoloft I felt really good I was
on nothing
[ __ ] yeah I was I was more emotional but
it was still I was good yeah I was like
I'd cry kind of without warning like
like I would get just like quickly upset
and then I gave me a pH I'll [ __ ] try
anything I don't give a [ __ ] oh wait
sure why not but it was like a bad
formula it was like a cream so then I
started having panic attacks on stage
here on HGH the curry yeah I was on the
clear I was on Barry Barry Bonds is fun
it's like protocol the SPF
milkshakes yeah yeah that's funny yeah
it was crazy so I started having panic
attacks on stage I was like [ __ ] this is
not a antic attack the night before I
did my Netflix three mics ah yeah so and
you talked about this on one of the
special you talked about the trans crash
yeah yeah and three much yeah so so so
that I did that and then it started to
panic Rex I was like f [ __ ] I guess it
didn't work so then I went back on
Zoloft
and I still felt good from the the
transcranial but you know I'm always
looking I'll do anything
okay I don't kids or wife or anything
right so so you uh you do the show in
Shanghai and I'm always looking to just
travel and I'd rather go to to Tokyo
than like Milwaukee right it's like more
interesting right yeah definitely super
unique um
and right before we go I just want to
what did anything else that you tried so
oh I also tried ketamine ketamine the
the drug right but that they do that
clinically now for depression and I
didn't like it other people liked it I
just didn't like it didn't work for me
so so so you just shown Shanghai text
and again I also do Milwaukee but if I'm
just gonna do if I'm want to go away for
a weekend I'm [ __ ] so i go to i go i
tech I email you I said what's you did a
show in Shanghai who's the guy
this guy he was like yeah I do was shown
Shanghai but also my brother is a like
neurosurgeon and he's very involved in
the transcranial the TMS community oh
wow and I know that yeah so it's a new
thing so he's like if you want to do TMS
while you're here and do the show that
Chinese TM a man Jesus so yeah man so
last week I did that [ __ ] Chinese
Tammis bro and I'm in a Chinese hospital
in Shenzhen China and I'm getting so the
first time I did TMS was here but his
brothers got this brain mapping software
where they can see
what parts of your brain are
communicating well with other parts of
your brain so they basically found that
the back of my brain which the serotonin
Center wasn't communicating well with
the rest of my brain so I got [ __ ]
zapped in the back yeah and on the right
side for for five basic ten sessions a
day for four days straight yeah I went
and did the damn thing like and so a
[ __ ] sweater with you Tony on that
yeah [ __ ] I'm on that [ __ ] that
unlimited [ __ ] I'm on the unlimited
power right now did you feel that what
what happened I feel good I don't want
to do this thing where like I'm in love
I don't I'm just like I feel good I
think it's better but I don't wanna
it was elective it wasn't like I was
like I couldn't I'm just like a zombie
in life I I want I'm trying to optimize
my trying to optimize my [ __ ] life
yes to feel good not to produce not to
rise & grind not to make a bigger profit
than I did last year just feel good have
a fun time yeah enjoy myself do weird
[ __ ]
just you should go to Shenzhen China go
to Hong Kong go to [ __ ] Shanghai I
love hearing that man cuz sometimes I'll
forget that that is the goal that that
the goal is to feel good sometimes it's
like I know it originally I knew it yeah
but sometimes then I forget that that
what an important goal that is you know
it's like these are all these other kind
of ways to say it and ways to like you
know replace it almost get put in you
put it you organize it it gets organized
in a way cuz you think about when you're
like 10 during the summer right oh yeah
what were you trying to do you just get
up just try to get some [ __ ] poppin yeah
just write it in short just try to get
some [ __ ] poppin I try to put your
sandals on dirtbike around [ __ ] these
guys are over there and them at the edge
of the woods yeah they're doing some
[ __ ] then you go over here you get some
candy you get and you can
keep doing that yes a different way yeah
just you just can do it are you work and
you do all that stuff but just see what
else is just get some [ __ ] what do you
like doing do that I like doing stand-up
here's what I realized I like doing I
like doing stand-up I like directing
commercials I like writing jokes and
talking to black people to talking of
course and I like just like just [ __ ]
[ __ ] around watching [ __ ] on the
Internet going on the inital online
three hours you like you're kind of a
little bit of a Magellan on the UH
mental health front a little bit I mean
it seems yeah nobody talked about it no
and that's the other thing is nobody
talks about it yeah and I don't have any
shame I don't think it's any weirder I
don't think that having depression is a
weakness I don't think it's any weaker
than having tendonitis yeah oh I'm just
like you I don't know let's see I'll try
to treat it I'm not gonna make it like I
don't I'm not trying to make it a heavy
thing yeah but I whenever I see you I
try to talk about your feelings or your
emotions like cuz dude that's the thing
the reason why that clip of you is
popular is because everyone wants to
talk about it but most places it's kind
of like a you know I'm sure after shows
you have as many people that just like
you because you're funny and and and and
quirky and then there's also people are
like hey man can I talk to you about
such-and-such
yeah a lot of people come out a lot of
people are struggling yeah yeah I didn't
realize that I guess that so many people
were having tough times but then I look
at all the people that are dying to meds
and dying to this and that yeah man
people really are struggling yeah do you
think that one of the reasons a lot of
young men are struggling is because just
like the way we've changed from being
like really like limbic like things we
need to do hunt get milk get honey get
you know yeah you know attack stuff do
stuff be they are connected to the earth
and then now we've become this separate
sort of just it's almost like we're just
like a straw
thing we're house cats being contained
yes we're indoor cats now so it's
[ __ ] scary
well yeah it'll make you start to you
know well we're you know it's a these
are all luxury problems right right yeah
no they're luxury problems I'm not
saying it like you I'm not compliance
Tway it's the this goes from the
delivery America for the richest
American most of our shits taking care
of our basic needs right yeah and if I
don't want to do [ __ ] you can just
[ __ ] let the government give you
money every mommy yeah it's like you you
can you can get taken care of in this
country yes so once you've got your
basic needs taken care of then you start
getting philosophical right and start
eating away and like am i pleased right
am i happy as much as where I'm [ __ ]
on the bar conversation like no but
problems with a robbery are we a side
effect but a problem is a problem it's
right if your problem is I need water
today or your problem is or I brain
doesn't feel good today yeah if that's
still a problem yeah and I think I would
that what I do is I try to treat it the
same way I treat it I'm hungry which is
I need food I need some I'm gonna do
something to treat my brain right I'm
going to [ __ ] China bro yeah they got
them good zappers over there I'm going
to China like that I honestly that's
that's kind of my thinking yeah like
we're set up enough that we can just
even if you work 60 hours a week that's
did you still have a lot of us still a
decent amount of free time like that you
and what do you want to do with it
to treat the rest of it like the you're
hunting just what are you hunting for
yeah if it's you're hunting for answers
there's plenty of fit you can do there's
plenty of [ __ ] you can listen to plenty
of books you can read plenty of 12-step
stuff you can meditate you can pray you
can there's so much [ __ ] you can do
that's not like yeah there's a lot of
new therapies out there things are
coming out all the time there's new ways
that people are thinking you know
there's podcast people to listen to
people to share like share what's going
on with them what was China like do you
think what do you think of the Chinese
be honest
and I wasn't gonna be honest till you
yell that at me
I was like I had a bunch of lies in the
chamber i hears I like here's what I'll
say Chinese women were better looking
than I thought okay because I think that
they get a bad rap I think the Japanese
women get too good a rap and Chinese
women get don't get enough props I
respect that
thank you and I've never been in a
communist country before so what I found
really [ __ ] crazy and I just talking
to Brian and talking to other people was
that they don't really tell you anything
there are rules that that are given to
you there's no legislation hmm there's
no government that you can lobby and get
a law they just make laws and they make
rules and those the rules and the other
thing is sometimes they enforce them
sometimes they don't and they don't tell
you when they're gonna force them and
when they're gonna not and that's [ __ ]
scary
that's scary so I was doing a show in
Shanghai and I said are there things I
shouldn't talk about and they said don't
talk about the three T's Tibet Taiwan
and Tiananmen Square those those are the
touchy subjects so I was like I don't
really have anything to say about those
things anyway now they are putting
Muslims in concentration camps are they
yeah the the called the we Gers and like
millions of them and so I did a joke
about that a lot of we Gore's in Detroit
you know they be honest with ya and so
now you say you might doesn't [ __ ] I
made a joke about that which I was like
and then literally a black woman came to
shell was like better go ahead with that
[ __ ]
in the front row like don't [ __ ] they
will [ __ ] wrap you up by the way
there's no due process so if you get
arrested we'll let you go when we let
you go the judges are just people that
just were like I'm not gonna say there
were just guys that were hanging out at
the courthouse but it's close like Brian
was saying like if you just have
seniority
you'll get you become a judge you don't
have to have a law so they're all just
actors almost in a not actors but
they're all just kind of pieces of this
apparatus dude right it's also 1.6
billion people so as much as we go make
it it's like how what kind of parent
would you be yeah if you got to put you
got to lay the law - but Brian was
telling me this thing where they you
don't have to there's no real regulation
there so people will build high-rise
yeah I saw some of those things without
without they don't tell anyone they just
own the property no like yeah we're
gonna build it and then if you don't
know the right person Brian was telling
me they they are they there was a place
that had there was a high-rise building
like a you know probably 100 units
whatever they but they didn't talk to
the right people so the government said
hey residents go to a spa this weekend
but we're gonna put you up out of this
place you got it you got to leave the
building for the weekend we're gonna do
some repairs they knock the [ __ ] down
with all their [ __ ] in it no they just
the people the people who bought the
apartments didn't know that the [ __ ]
landlord didn't clear it so all their
shit's gone and there's nobody to talk
to right that's crazy that's crazy yeah
so so it's almost like but then the and
there's cameras everywhere everywhere
dude I don't know if you noticed they
have [ __ ] everywhere on the street
but there's no crime there's very little
crime so it's almost like there's 10
human rights there's 10 like human right
we'll come human rights and every
country goes alright we're gonna pick
five of them mmm cuz here there's not
cameras everywhere
you're not like you get your face scan
when you go to China yeah so they could
they if they thought I was a problem
they can just follow him they just do
the thing where's the face the face is
here the phase they can track me that's
right so here you're not tracked
basically other than Google and Facebook
the government's not track is Dateline
of course if you're really about your
[ __ ] Dave and here you're not tracked
but there's you might get shot at
Walmart yeah so it's like 50/50 yes it's
like which which which which human
rights do you want which which qualities
of life do you want it's a great man
this is a it's a it's a great uh you
know when you put something next to
something else yeah it was really
interesting like I found it [ __ ]
fascinating like Wow because you don't
feel as much like a human over there you
don't feel as much like an individual at
all and they don't seem like individuals
that was one thing I noticed a lot of
the Chinese people they didn't seem like
as much individuals everybody almost
seemed like okay this is where I'm
supposed to be right now this is where
I'm going it seemed like and I'm not
saying that that's a vol so a value
system like their society has never been
by the way Americans that wasn't a
individualism wasn't a thing until like
a hundred years ago cuz it's good for
capitalism yeah my good you're gonna
express yourself and your guy sell [ __ ]
all the [ __ ] merch and jackin you got
everyone's got their merch table it's
like in the world and in American
society so they're they don't even value
like now we're about family and
togetherness so that's the it's another
thing where like you get to be an
individual but then you end up that guy
at like cost you walking around just
feeling uncomfortable because you're not
in a tribe but you are you are an
individual yeah there you go man what
you this is what you wanted your sisters
happy as [ __ ] yeah yeah living by the
interstate with a bunch of kids as she
[ __ ] loves her kids and it's great
yeah like so it's just a it's and
there's a doubt there's a downside to
everything yeah and that's the downside
to to be in here is that you just feel a
little disaffected yeah the way we build
things it's uh it's yeah it's a little
bit more commercial to a bit more
individual you need to stand for this
you need to do this
look how [ __ ] alone you are there
later then they sell you all the books
how to be on alone it's like Jesus
Christ is all this yeah about the
movement what about them oh yeah no that
too but also now this yeah now this now
we sold you this we have another pant we
have another program we want to sell you
which is undoing the first program but
that really is as much as it's a joke
like that you feel alienated oh it's
exactly it's yeah yeah I found in China
and I was also shocked in Shanghai when
I was there how many how few European
and Americans were there I didn't see
very many no it's that's when I told
somebody it's not only do they not speak
English it's like they never heard of it
yeah like they don't what what I mean I
had a guy you get in cabs and they don't
speak a [ __ ] word of the word of the
words you speak they don't know any of
them I had a guy you would love this so
I get in it like it kind of cab where
the guys like 1 100 which is like 8
bucks
he's like 1 and I was like all right
cool like kind of a chubby like 30 year
old Chinese dude it was gratifying cuz
you just go these Chinese and you know
you're right where is he he's agent
everybody write Chinese for all agents
and now you're racist yeah but they're
you just guys some Chinese guys right
but uh but uh so I get like it so he
takes me to my hotel and he goes uh to
and I go oh like all right [ __ ]
I say we were going see the upset yeah
he goes uh I charge you double he like
literally heard that in a movie I charge
you double like he he just turned on
like a kid like a [ __ ] evil character
so I'm like I'd like I almost wanted to
record I'm saying it again like so I
give him two and he goes ok it's cool
man it's cool like he just was taking
things he'd seen in movies and just
played them back-to-back
that was awesome but he didn't speak any
that's the English he spoke was from
that's great
yeah was I charge you double and it's
cool [ __ ] we Zaza yeah that's what he
that's what he knew so I enjoyed it in
that it was a it was a Ella straight
Avadh American context right it put
American life in context which I
appreciate it now do you think it's I
found it interesting like here it's like
everybody come here you everybody's
welcome here your Everett but then they
are it's not like they're like you can't
just stay there easily and just it's not
like I don't know if that's true though
I don't uh I have a ten-year reason do
you really yeah you're gonna buy for a
10-year visa they can eat you can either
do like a six-month one and people like
just get a ten-year one like that and
they uh they've just said that it's
extremely hard but you'd always shocked
it just how few anyone outside of
Chinese people I saw they're white black
no yeah there's Manos Mexicans yeah
there were no they just wear how people
it's people don't want to go people
don't want to go to [ __ ] China it's
not a tourist spot a little bit but I'm
not I'm not dying to go back I will but
I'm not well and now Hong Kong's [ __ ]
up to the fighting I did a show in Hong
Kong like then not like during and I it
was like my buddy sent me a video
walking home after the show like through
a [ __ ] zone of bricks and chaos like
it's [ __ ] up there yeah and and I
didn't realize like they're fighting for
their there basically a democratic
government and China is going like no
not anymore so people's lives are gonna
be [ __ ] up they're gonna they're gonna
be in that system we're like no you're
going to jail and there's no will let
yeah when if if we get around to it
that's gonna get itchy yeah that's what
they're fighting for like and I get that
like now that I've seen how [ __ ] is or
my understanding of how [ __ ] is in China
I'm like yeah I would fight I'd throw
Molotov cocktails - yeah cuz it's what's
the alternatives worse like
significantly worse yeah of not ever
fear not feeling
human yeah I started to feel like people
there that at a certain number of people
you start to realize that things seem
very much like ants almost yeah yeah but
at that number that it is like ants just
watching everybody like even when I was
on the trains
yeah the zone and you see somebody built
something no [ __ ] Windows never put a
roof on it [ __ ] disappeared yeah like
what yeah what happened there yeah I
mean after [ __ ] next do it like did you
go to Hong Kong insane zoning nah I it's
there are 70 storey buildings this far
from each other yeah like there's just a
walkway between them you know like this
is you could it this is [ __ ] crazy
and China I'm sure it's worse like I
didn't really walk her I walked around a
little bit it it actually might it
looked like have you been in Saudi
Arabia yes it looked like it felt like
I've never been to Saudi Arabia but
those like four lanes both ways oh yeah
yeah I was like sad kind of Vegas II
like Las Vegas Boulevard there was a lot
of that in Shenzhen yeah and yeah
there's a lot of that when you're on the
train you just see stuff it's like oh
did somebody start something here it
never happened small like little towns
it just tons of building but no windows
nobody live in there yeah like oh okay
so maybe they are yeah you don't know
they could be living there just not
great yeah yeah they're not having a
great or maybe they're your sister yeah
Chinese version your sister where
they're living there and they're having
a blast I couldn't tell how happy people
were there that's one thing I couldn't
tell and that's one problem I've always
had with a lot of Asian cult people
really if I'm real honest but like I
just can't
it's hard for me to read their vibes
because I don't really I didn't I don't
have enough of an experience and being
around a lot of Asian people to know if
they are like happy or unhappy I also
think it's the the value thing that what
is is that even a unless you're saying
is that even thinking about that yeah is
that even a concern like is Bobbili
happy that's a good question I don't
know it could be a documentary is Bobby
Lee happy gets enough rest to be happy
that's for sure dude I mean you talk
about doing I mean all he does is play
video games and sleep probably his car
you see many hits and Ripley's [ __ ]
Cup though
he hid Sam's car graduated because he
plays of candy crush on a tablet while
he drives which is in and his car has so
many dings and it's been so many acts
but one day ya hit his Tebow's his car
in the back part got out of the car well
it was still in Drive that's how it hits
Sam's car we may have the video still
yeah he what the car was in Drive and he
just like had his foot on the brake and
he stepped out of his vehicle and did he
watch it hit the car or did he try to
get back in mm-hmm I don't know his
whole body feels like an ass cheek I
realized the other day at but you're
absolutely right it's shaped like it is
shaped like some smooth ass cheek yeah
the front and the back oh yeah
yeah he's got like he goes it it does
this on the front and he always says
he's Korean I'm like who [ __ ] cares
bro can you back it up this was after
the aftermath
like how he said he'll pay for it like
it's like I'm gonna go I'm a magnanimous
person I'll pay for it like no yeah of
course you're gonna pay for it
that's hilarious yeah yeah like that is
it is there's a there's a stereotype but
like there does seem to be a stoicism to
Asian people generally like but it's not
I don't think that that's I think that
they're especially if their parents were
immigrants or their second generation
it's that they just it's like they're
here to achieve right and improve their
lives and like emotion and I don't care
that's not a concern
yeah motions oh wonderful motions more
of a white thing
maybe I mean it's it's yeah it's a I
also think like as much as your I think
it's okay I think some sensitive than
others right you're a sensitive guy I'm
a sensitive person yeah I think that
there are sensitive it I think Bobby's
sensitive too but he just doesn't he
just is like doesn't shoving it and
punching it and like just like I think
it's okay to be sensitive yeah it's it
is uh yeah it's an elective it's a it's
a it's a luxury item for certain people
but I don't think that I think you've
been sensitive since you were dead broke
yeah yeah and it probably felt that and
you thought it was because of that and
it's like no you're just like that yeah
yeah that's a good point to just
realizing some of that some things are
just position like you said if you're
like me you like to smell nice and well
and healthy sometime maybe you'll get a
put a pimp pimp em permit pepper mint in
your mouth and then tape it to your back
of your shirt collar and on the inside
get that natural law pheromone that
minty pheromone that Farah meant
smelling good is very important that's
what I'm trying to say and what I'm also
trying to say is Hawthorne has a new way
to help you smell really good Hawthorne
Cologne is very unique in that it has a
quiz on their website
you can take it or have a loved one take
it and it will help you figure out which
scent is right for you and your style
you don't you don't want to leave the
house wearing barbecue if you're going
to a funeral but you don't want to leave
the house wearing a embalming fluid if
you're going to a family picnic so let
the Hawthorne Cologne quiz help you out
it's a two-minute quiz and Hawthorne
tells you the two colognes that are best
for you one for work and one for play
it's risk free with free shipping and
free returns check out Hawthorne at
Hawthorne dot-com that's Hawthorne with
an e eh aw th ou are in e.com and use my
promo code Theo to get 10% off your
first purchase quit deciding what you
smell like let the specialists help
Hawthorn Cologne Hawthorne with an e
dot-com with promo code Theo for 10% off
and now back to the episode yeah you
think that you're having an old dad what
do you think that how do you think that
affected you I think it made me a lot of
shame and I really look back at it a
little bit in some way sometime I think
genetically like do I have real old
genes you know yeah like if I rest or if
I'll be real you know if I'll lay down
and like kind of make a name may say
something real loud or like you know
talk about God or something and lean
back in my chair or something like that
like my dad used to do that kind of
stuff if um yeah I wonder if my genes
are just real old you know I'm not gonna
agree you know I'm not bad at sex but
I've never really been like a real I'm
kind of like the indiana pacers of sex
you can go on and so it's like yeah I
can't make the playoffs appetize yeah
but it's not you're not going deep in
the playoffs yeah
you're not going past the first round
Reggie Miller left hasn't been yeah and
even then we were just shooting three
beers a boring slow pace yeah yeah
getting up and down the court yeah
hopefully
white audience but now you have a you do
have interesting sex habits right yeah I
just for me I think it's all a lot of it
just is always felt like a little bit
uncomfortable I kind of have that
perversion that came from like watching
a lot of pornography and then just just
the interaction this the connection
sometimes has always felt like I don't
like having a woman sleep over like some
of those things make me extremely
nervous like just well sometimes I mean
it's you know what the it's a real
obvious thing to say but it's it's real
intimate yeah it is it's real I mean
even if you're just talking about like
their face is right there yeah like
yours [ __ ] faces to [ __ ] like we're
both here especially if you're not drunk
oh yeah it's really like Nikki Glaser's
been doing a whole thing about having
sober sex and it's like it's for
children it's over sex is for children
I've always thought that you can't walk
sober bruh be young you know and oh yeah
it can't be 11 bro by the way I this is
I got to an argument on line last week
do you know that there's no minimum age
for sex to eight-year-olds can legally
have sex Wow and that crazy it gets into
illegal legally stuff starts happening
when you turn 16 then you actually can't
then you have to start being responsible
then you can't [ __ ] and nine year old
can legally [ __ ] a six year old Wow if
they're both consenting right [ __ ]
mind blowing but once you turn 16 then
you then you have like it you have a
license basically and you can't you you
can't go below 16 or you can go bull out
you can go three years below yeah yeah
that was a big thing when I was growing
up like seeing if somebody's 3 years old
or 3 years younger you'd always hear
things and people date and uh yeah you
always had that dude that would pull
over by the middle school and he drove
already and he'd come back and see his
[ __ ] girlfriend him handsome
McDonald's over the fence uh-huh dude
this one guy [ __ ] ham is some fat he
drove like this banana yellow Cutlass
and he painted some [ __ ] McDonald's
over the fence to his girlfriend it was
easily about 13 years yeah how did she
look
what she could look like what she is
they're sure she was thick
yeah they misplace that for age a lot of
times in rural communities you know
yeah like damn she is like I don't like
farming yeah you know man like she's of
eight she's Jenny she's Rhett she's
ready yeah it's like there's grads she's
of cat she's not a calf anymore yeah so
let's let's go yeah let's play ball
let's get a [ __ ] family pack of runts
and [ __ ] yeah so so yeah that's the but
this dude floored at one time he's
trying to show off in his whole
catalytic converter just fell off the
bottom of his car and I just remember
being you know about cars absolutely
hilarious not that much I know about
catalytic converters and I know about
pouring like a little bit of gas up
there in the carburetor if that [ __ ]
won't start is that is that old trick
yeah and I'll I liked cars better when
it was just like the engine and the
motor you know I don't know the
difference I don't know if I do either
but I think one of the transmission you
lift up the hood there was two pieces
there in that air filter thing there was
the crank yeah cuz you're from a 1940
and you'd spray wd-40 in that [ __ ] air
filter and let that [ __ ] I don't know
[ __ ] like that's where I don't feel like
a man it's when car stuff having them
like I I don't know well now you drive a
[ __ ] now I don't need to know yeah he
driving a lot of muscle yeah I just
place her plug her in y'all got a outlet
that's way but that is nice is it just
well yeah just go like I don't need to
know I just I only go to the gas station
that wiped up for the wipers yeah
[ __ ] great and it's well yeah I guess
feeling emotional and also then feeling
I guess feeling like emotional about
[ __ ] are talking about that kind of
stuff but then also feeling like a you
can still feel like a man you like I
still do like you know I'll do like
insane [ __ ] at the gym and do insane
training and I'll [ __ ] probably
endanger myself a pretty good amount of
time you know I do you work out so yeah
I just started getting a trainer really
getting pretty much into it I'm trying
to start taking some Brazilian jiu-jitsu
yeah so yeah just to have like a it just
seems so cool just seems like a
just to have another circle of
camaraderie really yeah I it's also
boxing I did like Thai boxing and
Thailand one times like this is fun I
could see the hyphenation
he's got that physique doesn't he yeah
throwing combinations yeah like that's
[ __ ] fun bing bang bang duck ha
it's [ __ ] fun yeah and it's being
able to know that if somebody attacks me
and they don't know Brazilian Jiu Jitsu
that I would know enough couple of
tricks to be able to now the hard part
is not doing it all the time in
conversation oh right that's the fists
are like bro today
yeah thing today yeah any [ __ ] now
I'm not no disrespect to Bryan Callen
yeah the second thing he put somebody
yeah like no I could see the thing with
me you don't want to be one it's like
when you start working out and you
you're flexing for people yeah oh yeah
but you're not you're not kidding
yes some girl right with you touch your
arm you flex right before yep
oh absolutely that's yet so I'm glad
that you and thank you for not posting
workout videos oh yeah you bet I try not
to but ever since Chris D'Elia does some
without thinking about [ __ ] throwing
one up we can't fall for it
I feel like Kevin Hart started this oh
did he really does he do yeah he started
he would he shows well he doesn't a lot
of training videos
does he have writers probably for his
jokes and stuff now Kevin he has the
guys who opened for him the red plastic
cup boys but they don't it's all based
on [ __ ] that happened to him so it's not
I don't think he has writers really I
think he maybe they go maybe like a tag
here and there yeah but he doesn't have
writers as far as I know he is people
that he's with though yeah how are you
doing are you did you figure out how
you're gonna do your special I'm not
sure yet still not sure well we have any
offers really that I feel like her you
know that I feel like her the move
really part of me thinks about shooting
it and just putting clips out onto
YouTube like you know just putting the
stories out on YouTube and putting out a
CD you know an album just owning it yeah
and then
but then possibly doing Netflix they're
gonna come out in December mmm
so your tendency Mia and um so I think
you know they might there might be an
offer after that it's just also a time
schedule when they have room yeah they
said it might not be until the 2021 so
then that makes me think well at that
point I might as well just put some
clips or something like I want to have
some fresh stuff out there and also for
me to just and my brain to start to move
on yeah cuz I'm already building like a
new hour it does get kind of tough doing
some of the same stuff like jokes kind
of have like a point where they're like
at their peak you know it's fun Chapelle
you say jokes are like tires hmm where
it's like just the treads wear out yeah
and he's right because when you first
it's that disappointing thing when you
have a good new joke that first two
weeks that [ __ ] is [ __ ] popping
mm-hmm [ __ ] like vain the audience
knows it's new yeah it's like having
money at the mall oh it's the best the
new joke I would say it's like finding
money a pie it's like and then and then
after two weeks it'll settle yeah it'll
just go to like alright this is what
this is gonna get now from here on out
and then after a while it goes down
another level and it's to your point
getting shooting a joke at the right
time filming it at the right time is
like you don't want to wait too long
yeah because something about it even if
they haven't heard it it just doesn't
have the the [ __ ] energy yeah that's
kind of what I'm realizing
- it's like and a lot of this just
learning as you go it's like that's the
tough part it's like man I wish some all
this stuff I already knew it but you
know but that's my experience and it's
just you know and all you also shoot it
now and you know the great thing is if
you're already writing a new hour the
good that you have a you there's a
hundred cities now where you could sell
out right that's a thing - it's hard to
stop it's hard to stop going to cities
whenever you have an hour that people
haven't seen yeah because it's segura I
feel like has toured this hour for so
long and it's it's legitimately because
they they're cities he hasn't gone -
yeah and he's
probably tired it daliyah said he threw
out like 40 minutes on this tour because
he was doing the tour so long that he
wrote new jokes and just replaced the
other ones yeah so he could have gone
back to some of the cities with a new
hour on the same tour yeah that's where
I'm at I'm feeling like well shoot do I
just keep adding places because I've
been touring the same stuff for almost a
year and a half I mean it's definitely
evolved and changed but and there's new
stuff now I could put in but I'm like I
don't know what to do do I to start
putting in new start and save it if I
were you I'd save it and just start a
new to it because it seems like Bert did
that Bert's got it Bert's just finished
one tour he's starting another one yeah
I would if you have a new more time [ __ ]
it like when you have new [ __ ] that's
not topical or like it's not about some
[ __ ] that's happening now it's it's just
a story or [ __ ] it yeah like and then
just work on that on the during the week
and then on weekends do that
do you like the tour show yeah yeah it's
I think I think that's a I think also
yeah this show got tough to us trusting
my instincts and no one liked what was
the right thing to do and like you know
different things were coming in and I'm
like is this right I don't know what to
do you know yeah just a lot of fear this
year I think it made everything tough it
made it like I was all ready to kind of
shoot my special at Christmas and then
next thing you know it was like oh
there's a bunch more city you can go to
and you can you know and you can make
money and then it was like nervous
making money I felt like what do I do
what do you do with money not that much
really you know I do post maybe you
don't have to do anything that's the
thing people think you got to do
something with it you don't yeah we
haven't done anything yeah I mean I've
done post I do post makes more yeah yeah
you [ __ ] you order this [ __ ] out oh
dude I'll get these tacos twice a week
probably and then what else yeah I
probably not that much honestly I don't
like going to shop for stuff and I don't
like doing that kind of stuff I don't
either
I don't like like stuff it just doesn't
mean that much to me like I don't like
people take pictures of their shoes and
just like yeah I catered I don't know it
just doesn't I don't it doesn't move me
yeah it doesn't move me so I don't know
good like you probably won't be broke
yeah pay my mom's rent now and that's
gotta feel awesome it's nice to know she
don't have to worry she works hard she's
like 77 or something and she's still
like you know deliver stuff and um yeah
it is nice to know that she can take the
day off for something she wants to and
you have to [ __ ] think about paying
something that's gotta be it's pretty uh
that's god that's like gotta feel
outstanding
yeah it's not really about it yeah what
I how's the relationship talk about it I
never I've always had a tough time
hearing my mother you know I felt like I
don't know I just have always had a look
like uh I think you know sometimes I
think the reason I do comedies because I
wanted my mom to laugh or something I
was young and I couldn't get her to
laugh yeah and so I it like spun out
into this weird thing where that's what
I was doing you know because I remember
my dad laughing all the time but I never
met I've added you yeah just in general
yeah just laughing just having a good
time having a good - haven't you having
a good time yeah and then I don't
remember my mother having that at all
and I think there was always like this
stress that she was stressed and I
couldn't do anything
you know just yeah I think that's the
the the I've seen study a lot of
comedians is about making your mom laugh
yeah that's a big one as much as it's
like weird sad clowns and all that stuff
it's a lot of it's sad children children
of sad moms yeah honestly a lot of times
that's the formula for comedians
that should be a club yeah children
would sama my mom's not sad my mom is uh
I always felt like there's like
plexiglass between us mmm like ah like I
want a [ __ ] more of a connection and
we just can't get there yeah like we
just can't it just doesn't that's not
she doesn't know how to do it yeah she's
a good mom yeah it's like did the you
know like like attentive and all that
stuff just emotionally and that's that
that's another generational thing where
my mom's 85 so yeah like
I don't she doesn't know them like
emotion the [ __ ] are you talking about
yeah yeah we can't really think about
that kind of more than 19 she born
during the Great Depression yeah
1933 like I don't forget imagine she was
three Wow like she got split up like one
of her sisters went to Ireland and then
they couldn't pick her up because of the
war yeah yeah what we're not coming this
week does you have a Hitler can you
imagine that though all the time
especially on top mr. ug see all these
families just got split up yeah were
kids we couldn't afford it the
orphanages - yeah it's like like my
mom's mom died and then she had two
sisters maybe three and each uncle took
a different one or each aunt took a
different one but meanwhile the dad was
still alive they just were like yeah
yeah we're not leave not gonna dad
that's insane yeah this is the hill
they'll be dead in a week
and even with a guy so they went to the
aunts and then the dad was like I'm
getting ready and I was like mom how
long did he need to get ready for and it
he never really got it together Wow
yeah and then he remarried like his mate
just crazy [ __ ] 30s and 40s it but so
and then I'm like where's the feeling
but why is there blessing because the
[ __ ] Hitler and the Great Depression
that's why you [ __ ] shy yeah that's a
royal brat that's what I realized a lot
of times to men and I think about that
too about myself man I'm just a [ __ ]
brat like yeah at some point it's like
[ __ ] I also have to realize look dude
you have to just [ __ ] take care of
yourself you have to find a way to do it
you can't think at a certain point you
can't think about all this [ __ ] too much
it's a / - life's a plan of a program of
action you got to take action and get
yourself feeling good you got to get
yourself doing something you have to
just get going you know yeah it's crazy
to think sometimes that yeah our parents
who probably had no whose parents to
them probably didn't teach them much
about emotions or anything at all the
Rockefeller
probably had emotions brah they were
[ __ ] all out of their minds - yeah
they'd like the Rockefellers doing like
no the Rockefellers parent John Rocker
Bella's dad was probably a [ __ ] coal
miner yeah there wasn't well you know I
mean like they there wasn't like crazy
like three people were rich yeah
everybody else [ __ ] lived in
Appalachia yeah I mean not literally but
like there was no like well there was a
robust middle-class no life was [ __ ]
brutally everyone [ __ ] in an outhouse
like even if you were there there's this
book called sapiens it's really good but
they were so the guy was saying like
there were French French like the king
of we live better than the King of
France from 1700 Wow Wow
King of France 17-under shat out side
damn know in didn't have he had somebody
to carry it out there for me ya know
Pete had hell he ain't goin by him by
himself but like he didn't have a [ __ ]
there was no indoor heat no indoor air
game there's no he no car no like
nothing
so no ice no ice Theo so so we have it
good but at the same time it's not
perfect yeah
damn yeah you'd have somebody whose body
timbers was a little Lotus blow on you
all that yeah just bring in the cool and
hey and he would blow on it yeah like we
don't we it's hard
put problems or problems problems or
relics right no as much as you are like
as much as its if they were alive today
they'd have the same problems we have
yeah
which is I don't feel quite right I
don't feel I feel isolated feeling
alienated I feel emotionally I feel
whatever all the things that we deal
with that's our version of shooting
outside yeah yeah it's our version of
sitting outside in the product but that
but then the the part that we can
control is how do we what do we do about
it yeah taking action or not taking
action yeah and I think yeah for me this
show just got caught in a place where I
was in everything else was too much and
I wasn't able to focus on that at all
and so now I'm like a
get back to focusing on it and it's
definitely getting more manageable Nikki
had something bout donkeys I have to
text my sponsor real quick or he's gonna
[ __ ] yeah we had it we had a couple
news stories one you guys talked about
China a lot the world's donkey
population is set to be halved in the
next five years because it's a good
traditional Chinese medicine that is
being used
it's estimated that four point eight
million donkey hides a year are used for
a gelatin based medicine that the
Chinese use well the thing that I don't
know if it was in the news here they're
also harvesting organs over there in
China yeah well you'd have to at a
certain point I mean anything becomes
like a everything becomes a food you
know here we call it a dead or not
eating them they're prisoners they're
killing prisoners and taking their
organs you don't have to do what via
what video okay this is song no I'm
serious yeah there you go
harvesting organs China Resort
horizontal dress oh but dude for
transplant look here's what I say if the
guys in for life take his [ __ ] liver
bruh and give it to somebody who can use
it man I think we could get a lot more
out of our prisoners sometimes that
we're under using them that's a great
resource that we're not yeah the guys in
there with two Long's and somebody you
know we got somebody's gonna die a
cystic fibrosis [ __ ] pull the airbag
out of that cat and throw them into
somebody who can use it and you're
willing to go on the right this is this
is gonna be your platform for running
for mayor sorry uh uh hold on one second
that's fine yeah no they're harvesting
organs it's not great despite wouldn't
the oh thanks well I'm not saying
everybody gets an organ I'm saying that
you know you believe that rich people
should get them first because that's but
I know that what's happening but sister
got a liver and uh and it was definitely
at a certain point we're like Oh what do
you mean this person somebody else is
getting in before yeah yeah but that's
it's cool that they're kind of they kind
of it doesn't matter how rich you are
you can't the donor the list is the list
this is a list and you can't how did
your city is did it take you
it took she got him she's like 14 and
she's got that yeah just take
anti-rejection medicine because your
body's always like this thing is in
yours you know what's funny that's
almost like what a a is for you like you
have to take your anti-rejection
medicine yeah like you have to like your
body's like this in right yeah I don't
like it yeah you're like no body we have
to go that's what I remember going I
used to go to Al Anam which was like for
not drinking it's for being in
relationships with alcoholics and drug
addicts yeah and and you yeah I'll call
this um so bad there's two programs for
it has a program for if you just know
people who do who are it they but that's
I realize like no I got to do this all
the time you have to do this I have I
can't this is a chronic set of behavior
on my part like from from my dad's an
alcoholic so just you build your brain
in a certain way and you have to undo it
yeah yeah it is it is it's a daily thing
it really is man it's like I know if I
get up and do my meditation and I do my
gratitude list and I call other guys
that or have the same problem then I
will have a better chance of having a
better day mm-hm
do you call people every day getting up
and thinking about myself yeah I call
people every day the other - I've
struggled with but now I'm getting a lot
back I've been really just focusing on
it really especially the past maybe
month trying to get back into you when
you didn't feel grateful did you not do
a gratitude list or you would just write
like [ __ ] just stare at the paper
somedays yeah well just couldn't feel it
I would write it but I couldn't
yeah yeah and that was the worst man
yeah god I want to feel grateful and I
just and then just travelling a lot
doing the shows and stuff it was just
hard
just getting on and off of planes and
waking up here there and not knowing
what was going on had being halfway
through a sense sometimes like I'm so
happy to be here in and thinking in my
head what city is this yeah [ __ ]
alarming they're hard but that has to do
with just wear and tear like that if you
don't know what city it's hard to
remember
when you're you look at the schedule and
you like I'm going there then I'm going
there then we go there and you're like I
don't even know what week it is time you
ever have the thing where you don't know
what period of your life you're in you
ever have that like where you'll be like
did I have I started podcasting yet
where you'll be on the 405 or them
you'll be just drivin and you'll be like
where I have it sometimes where I'll go
to a city I'll be like have I done it
what period of my life of my in yeah my
28th mi-28 I'm 40 what like alright did
I do that yet am i comedian yet or did I
still am I still not a committee I don't
know
the you have a gratitude thing is it's
hard that I do you travel well I travel
pretty well but then yeah this year did
everything just got a little bit too
much it just was oh it just got to be
too much but air travel [ __ ] me up
oh yeah it's bad man it's really tough
on your body and it's tough on you over
a while too yeah you know I've been
doing it for 15 years traveling doing
touring so it's like and this year was
just the most it's been and it was just
and it was just it kind of caught up to
me and I started taking on one thing
that was the worst for me this year I
didn't realize was I took propecia ah
dude I wanted to kill myself for like a
month
and I had never felt that way in my
entire life and it was because of that
bro I had no idea and I got off of that
bro and everything started to get better
that's crazy it was I don't think we
that's the thing about that they talk a
lot about the pill and how it [ __ ] up
women's bodies and it absolutely does
but that people don't talk about
propecia very much as like this thing
guys do that's purely for to look good
yeah and it [ __ ] people up like it
[ __ ] if there are ways in which
propecia [ __ ] people up I've never
taken it but I like hearing that I'm not
I've heard that [ __ ] before or you have
erectile dysfunction or you there's just
a bunch of problems yeah just trying to
hold on to your hair
yeah yeah and then what they say is even
with the erectile dysfunction so what it
messes up is your libido so that's why
the side effect of that is your erection
right but for in some people but when it
mess up your libido for me it just
messed up that massive whatever
masculine energy whatever we bet I had
left you know if I could just crippled
it so dude it was just like bro I had
some of the scare I had never felt and
so I threw that in this year and it was
just like man it was just fog brah
it was just that [ __ ] was tough and I'm
so glad I realized after minoxidil makes
a pill that's a less dose and they also
say you can take half of a propecia and
this won't happen but but minoxidil
makes a pill as well and I mean now I
take that and I don't have any side
effects yeah great yeah yeah that's
significant yeah it was so scary because
then it was just at the time I'm like
[ __ ] is I am I just completely fall
apart yeah and no you were just trying
to hold on to your hair and hold on to
my hair man that's all it's simple guy
that simple man that might be the name
of this episode um I gotta go meet my
sponsor man yeah of course thank you so
much I love talking about yeah me too
man and I really like really really
happy for you and it's cool I'm happy
like you were [ __ ] hilarious dude
thanks man and and I'm happy that you're
that people realize it thanks man
yeah man well appreciated I appreciate
coming on and yeah I love how you always
have new material and you're a hard
worker man I really admire that about
you yeah thank you yeah all right god
bless
[Music]
like these leaves I must be oh but when
I reach that round I'll share this piece
of my I can feel it in my throat it's
gonna take
little time for me to sell that parking
brake
Oh
[Music]